you have a second envelope another
Academy Award to present the nominees
for best achievement and documentary
feature our and Frank remembered John
Blair
the battle over Citizen Kane Thomas
Lennon and Michael Epstein fiddle fest
Roberta
SOT varis and her East Harmon violin
program Alan Miller and Walter Shore
Hank Aaron chasing the dream michael
Tolan and Frederick Golding troublesome
Creek a Midwestern genie Jordan and
Steven Asher and the Oscar for
documentary feature goes to and Frank
remembered John Blair
[Applause]
[Music]
Anne Frank loved the movies in October
1942 she even wrote that she wanted to
come to Hollywood of course that was a
dream that she could never realize but
in bringing her story to Hollywood I
must thank Michael at will at the BBC
Doug Zwick Nancy Kemp and Bruce Ryder at
Disney and all the people at Sony
Pictures Classics and most especially
Steven Spielberg without whose 11th hour
intervention
I would never been able to make this
film but most of all it's this woman the
hero of the story of Anne Frank the
woman quite literally without which they
would never have been a diary for us to
celebrate for 50 years ladies and
gentlemen this is Miss who found the
diary on the floor you don't be pissed
in the city of celluloid heroes nip is a
true hero
[Applause]